Measuring frames per second is a common way to talk about an application as a
whole. If an application runs at 10 frames per second on one system and 20
frames per second on another, we can truthfully say the second system is about
twice as fast in this instance. However, graphics programmers themselves have
been moving towards using the inverse of frames per second. Miliseconds the
seconds per frame. There are number of good reasons for this. The most
appealing one to me is that milliseconds give you a solid number for use in
comparison of different algorithms. If you talk about an algorithm's
implementation in terms of milliseconds per frame, you can then treat the
effect on speed as a single number. This user interface is costing us five
milliseconds per frame is a useful fact in its own right. This user interface
slows us down by 10 frames per second. It's not all that helpful, since we
don't know what the frame rate was before. Reading individual parts of the
rendering process by frames per second, doesn't make a lot of sense, since it's
the sum of the cost that's important. You can add millisecond costs together to
see how much a frame will typically take. Games for example will often have a
budget of say 33.3 milliseconds per frame, which means 30 frames per second. If
different effects cost various amounts of time, it's easier to add these up and
see if we're over budget. If an application aims for 60 frames per second, the
budget is halved. Another reason to avoid frames per second is that they're
difficult to work with mathematically. So, of course, that's what I'm going to
ask you to do, to get a feel for this sort of problem. You measure your
application. Say it's a walk through of a building. Here are the rates you
find. 25 frames per second for 100 frames. 50 frames per second for the next
100 frames. 25 frames per second for the next 100 frames. And then 10 frames
per second for the last 100 frames of your benchmark. What is the average speed
of the application in frames per second? I'll give you a hint, simply averaging
the frames per second values is not going to work. Think about how many frames
are rendered and how many seconds passed during the entire benchmark. You might
want to translate this problem to thinking about miles per hour.